I was I also add that I we adore you but
I also just want to give a lot of props
to to Rose I know firsthand what it's
like to grow up and certain family
members of mine that grew up in not very
how do I say like with great
accommodations very similar to Rose
actually actually my niece here who's in
the room grew up in very similar
circumstances in the Philippines and it
was hi the fact that she was kind of
thrust into this world with cameras and
all of this I really got to say that she
is I've watched other seasons of 90 days
before the 90 days and I haven't always
been a fan of like how like younger
Filipinos are portrayed but she I really
liked how I really like her and I really
commend her for kind of like standing
her ground and going through that
experience with you I do too and listen
um you won't see you never will and yet
you never have seen one negative thing
that I would say about her anywhere
online I would never ever in a million
years disrespect her in any way nor did
I ever intend to disrespect her or the
country the Philippines they that was
probably one of the nicest countries and
I just got back from Japan right in
April where they're just super courteous
that the people of and that's why I love
that culture because they're so they're
just such a loving and caring and
family-oriented people and it's just i
think you know i landed i you know
twenty three hour flight
i had no sleep it was like a hundred
degrees the humidity I like if I don't
sleep with air conditioning I'm screwed
that's not like a makeup I sleep you
know with an air conditioning air
conditioner on like 24/7 so literally
I'm miserable though I was just
miserable the whole time in and I'd
probably you know like when you're in it
you're not really thinking about how how
you're being and it's just I respect her
she's a great mother and I would never
let anybody take that away from her I
mean I oh that's sweet dude Michi she
feels a little bit differently I'm sure
you know she's mad but and she says some
things about me but I will never ever
you'll never hear another you've never
heard one find it or will you ever hear
me say many asparagine I won't complain
about her other than
you know she I I look at her footage I
mean look you know I was in love with
her like people think I did this for the
show I mean I've I'm a foot massage was
a pure law brother you have to bring
that up okay that night first of all I'm
like massage and relax and look yeah
your foots any all right
women women laser their body right they
laser than hair so it just caught me off
guard I wasn't used to it and and so you
know like it's my it wasn't what I was
saying the whole time you know was just
how I was saying just no no I was I'm
not being facetious okay I'm telling you
that that foot massage was dope as [ __ ]
that's all dude women love foot massages
it's a ways to go to Tijuana and go to a
deleted a [ __ ] used to do my feet
when they came to the United States in
in when I was 15 I came to the United
States for the first time and I remember
specifically specifically being
humiliated for my unshaved legs that was
a thing that I just didn't know I ever
had to do it just wasn't a thing in the
Philippines so when I came here and I
wore shorts for the first time boys were
like why why are you wearing shorts yeah
wait what's what's happening and they're
like that's gross
you know shave your legs what did your
coochie look like bushes [ __ ] like a
jungle oh oh my god now I don't mind I
don't mind that at all but it so you
like bushy bushy I do I really do wow I
do love it think of think of James Bond
like the sixties models yeah I see but
no but it's just you know and then you
saw the scene where you know I'm you
know I gave her lingerie and I'm like oh
by the way you know I wasn't worried
about her breath and I'm like and I was
laughs oh yeah she had really bad breath
so I don't want to say look oh um you
know you makes you fresh cuz she didn't
know what I said this will make your
breath smell pretty your eyes oh and
then I thought you sell me she'd love me
but Jenna told me that I was like really
so you know I
apologize because I really didn't you
know you know say things I think as PC
as I should have but but I'm just
telling you guys that I would this is
who I mean and I'm I'm learning but this
is who I am i yes
I wasn't acting it was that's why and
then I come back and I go why didn't why
did I say that you know why did you know
but you know what I think that's what
people don't realize if we were to stick
cameras in each one of anyone's homes at
any given point in time and if that was
just the life that we were living my god
we'd have a hundred things a day that we
would regret yeah just I cringe even
looking like we record this podcast once
a week but even when I look back and I
have full control of what I say here and
I edit stuff I still cringe at the
things that I do and say and I regret a
lot of the things that I said 100
episodes of episodes ago it's inevitable
I tell you I believe you because because
when I because when I put the camera up
in my neighbor's house I'm like oh my
god they would be so embarrassed yeah
yeah this is before we go buddy I want
to say this if you ever want to promote
anything come to Target Bella we're here
for you I would love that man thinks a
man I know I didn't know they you know
this was set up by my publicist and when
I saw you my Kohli [ __ ] I know that I'd
see you everywhere oh thank you